good evening good evening I'm Jim
valentini I'm the Dean of Columbia
College and I welcome you all here
tonight on one of the happiest nights of
the year to see all of you together
today I was reading an important
document it says the trustees of
columbia university in the city of new
york consolidated financial statements
jun 30 2012 this document says that our
total assets are 13 billion 726 million
891 thousand dollars yeah and our
liabilities are three billion 74 million
eight hundred and forty thousand which
gives us net assets of 10 billion 652
million fifty one thousand dollars and
that's all elaborated in great detail in
this document of 39 pages and this has
been certified by PwC formerly known as
Price Waterhouse Cooper I think but it's
completely wrong I don't know what PwC
did wrong but it's completely wrong
because it doesn't list our actual
assets are our actual assets are in this
room all right I know what our assets
are yes indeed you
you are our assets now I'm not saying
that 10 billion 652 million dollars
isn't a lot of money and Phil milstein
is in charge of all that by the way but
it's not really what we have our assets
include mark Amsterdam Kira Barry Robert
Byrne yell fur gang Robert Friedman
Brian Chris Berg Daniel Loeb Frank Lopez
Balboa Victor Lopez Balboa Paul Madden
Gerald sherwin Daniel Tamkin Douglas
wolf and about 200 other donors who are
here tonight if I named you it isn't for
any other reason then I did not ask
permission to use anyone's name and so I
chose the names of people who I knew
would natsume over invasion of privacy
but you are not the only assets Leah
beltrami know James Chung Chelsea Davis
fábio de Souza Michael Garrett Marla
Gutierrez Patterson Simon Jerome Daniel
Kerrigan Cameron McClure Jennifer Mendez
Kimberly p anoche Misha Solomon and
grace wang are also assets but their
students here tonight they're not donors
their students we have as our real
assets only two groups of people faculty
and students students can be former
students or they can be current students
we also have as assets friends of
faculty and current students who support
us in the now 18 months I think that
I've been Dean I have talked to
literally thousands of people who are
interested in supporting the university
and the college I have in those
thousands of conversations I have asked
someone directly for money only three
times because you are assets are assets
I want to develop as friends and
supporters of the university
and asking you for money is not how I
develop that it is a relationship of all
of us to one another which is what makes
this event so nice we have many
generations of people in this room and
dividing us a primary really into two
groups those of us who are supporting
current students and current students
who are being supported by primarily
former students this is an important
relationship but the dichotomy between
those being supported and those
supporting is only apparent it's not
real all of you who are current
recipients of scholarships will someday
yourselves be former students for those
of you who are seniors that status as
former student is only a few weeks away
when you become former students and I
hope many of you will reap the rewards
personal professional and financial of
having been Columbia students I hope you
will remember this event and take your
place as donors for future generations
of students who will be attending the
college financial aid which were which
were celebrating tonight in the form of
named scholarships is one of the most
important activities tools that the
college has financial aid allows us to
admit what I say are the students we
should admit which are the students who
are best able to profit from being at
Columbia College and contribute to the
experience of being at Columbia College
the choice of students whom we view to
be those best able to contribute to and
profit from is only possible if other
constraint on the selection of students
are removed and one of the largest
constraints is the significant cost of
attending this or any other elite
college so financial aid is a tool that
allows us to create the college that
we have each of you donors is
contributing to building a college that
is very special in very many ways we are
the one of the most selective among the
top two or three most selective colleges
in the united states yet we're also the
most diverse selective college in the
united states we have the largest
percentage of students who are the first
in their family to attend college we
have the largest percentage of students
of color the largest percentage of
african-american students we have by any
measure that you can define an
individual many many many dimensions in
which you can define an individual we
have the most diverse student body
anywhere this is something I am very
very proud of but cannot alone take
credit for but the people in this room
who are donors to scholarships are the
people who make it possible for this
outcome to be achieved and I greatly
appreciate your support and I would like
to encourage all of our students tonight
to think ahead to see as I say many
times that current students can see
their futures in the presence and past
of former students I want our current
students to see their futures as donors
this event tonight by talking with you
the donors who have supported them now
tonight I'd like to in next introduce
James Brett Jim Brett who is now a
member of the board of visitors of the
college a very important group of people
to me Jim is currently on I so-called
sabbatical from jpmorgan sabbatical goes
back to a biblical prescription he
however didn't work at JP Morgan for
seven years before he took a sabbatical
he worked at JP Morgan for 17 years so
he more than earned this sabbatical he
is a member of the undergraduate
campaign council a former member of the
Columbia College Alumni Association
Board of Directors a graduate of the
cool
college class of nineteen eighty-four i
also see he is a graduate of a purported
school of business that we have at
columbia though I had thought we only
had a college at Columbia but I will
forgive him for that jim has been a very
enthusiastic supporter of the college in
every possible way and has himself with
his wife patricia class of nineteen
eighty-seven created the jessica Lee
Brett scholarship which were celebrating
tonight as well he has also generously
supported the king's crown rowing
association of which i am fondly and
honorary member so I'd like to introduce
Jim and give him a chance to talk to you
about his experience as a scholarship
donor and as a student in Columbia
College thank you
Thank You Dean a lot of the themes that
I heard Dean speak about I'm actually
going to touch on them as well and we
didn't compare notes firstly you know
worried about the Dean himself I think
we should all feel privileged and
honored that we have the benefit of Dean
Valentin ease passion leadership and
wisdom as the Dean of the college so
well done thank you do please I too
would like to welcome everyone here this
evening that includes the supporters
with the name scholarships all the
families and the student recipients we
are all here today because we are
invested in the future of Columbia
College this great college and the
strength of the club the college rests
on many pillars and amongst the most
important of these are need-blind policy
strong commitment to financial aid and
these scholarships such as those named
here which support the next generation
of qualified students our goal our
desire is to create an equal playing
field where we can and I think what we
see is the cost of a private college
education that these best universities
can be quite prohibitive so these
scholarships referred here allow us to
have the ability to retrack attract and
retain some of our best students the
academic field you know the war for
talent in the war for genius is amongst
the most competitive out there and we
don't want to lose any students
especially students that want to be here
deserve to be here you know just because
the financial math didn't work we want
to have qualified students and we don't
live in the computation whether it's
like you know the other top schools in
the country whether it's Harvard or Yale
or Princeton or in any these other
schools we want to remain competitive
these name scholarships are an important
part of that mission
and for me I think the best way to
describe the benefit of sponsoring a
student at each year for a scholarship
is if if one was to have a college that
and had only one cut of the type of
students that it can attract chosen from
a restricted or limited pool of talent
and we here can have a college that
supports diversity and diversity broadly
defined and that includes social ethnic
geographic economic diversity what we're
talking about here tonight which is
supporting families or students with
different financial means the college
that supports diversity wins every
single time and that college we talked
about it is Columbia and what we see in
this diversity I'm talk about talking
about it creates a richer academic and
social experience for the whole student
body everyone benefits everyone wins the
Dean talked a little about my my road to
Columbia my story and like he said
Columbia College 84 Business School
Columbia Business School 90 my wife with
the first coed class which my wife
Patricia which was 87 I've tried to be
actively involved where I could
undergraduate campaign counsel and like
you said I'm currently on the board of
visitors which is the advisory board for
Dean valentini and hopefully it's an
important resource for a decision making
I have three children James Alex and
Isabel three beautiful children I live
in Greenwich Connecticut today again my
road to Columbia is I actually grew up
in New York City and when I was deciding
on applying to a college columbia was my
number one choice and it was kind of
easy for me I viewed it simply as hey if
I go to Columbia you get a great
education you have new york city as your
playground you know sign me up but for
me to come to columbia it required a lot
of juggling i had loans i grant at
financial aid i actually worked my four
years through college and like so many
here
you know I directly felt the importance
of these types of commitments that are
made here tonight Colombia has given me
so much I think it's given us all so
much you know it helps shape my values
my goals my ethics my ambitions it
helped prepare me for career in Wall
Street you know 28 years working on Wall
Street in 17 years at JPMorgan well at
Columbia and I'm also still a member of
king's crown wrong association that
although haven't done it in quite a
while I wrote proof my four years at
Columbia I was captain at the co-captain
of the head of a crew team my senior
year and crew also taught me many
lessons which was another takeaway from
Columbia and what I learned is boats
don't go fast unless people work
together so I learned the value of
teamwork hard work healthy competition
and all that helped me you know guide me
in my life and in my professional career
five years ago my wife Patricia and I
made the decision to endow the jessica
lee bread scholarship fund it's named in
memory of my daughter Jessica passed
away in 2001 we wanted to support
something we both highly valued which is
a scholarship for a student at Columbia
you know felt it was important it was
all way of giving back you know my last
thought my last comment before I
introduce our student speaker is you
know I remember my freshman year at
Columbia which was nineteen eighty and
it was robably the first couple of
months of school and I was walking on
college walk just looking around and
something very very important hit me and
what I realized is you know no matter
what has to be the rest of my life go to
bed they can never take this away from
me and is that I was at Columbia so you
know I want my sponsored student
scholarship each year to give another
student you know that feeling that
opportunity and I wanted to help us
remain and help Columbia remain what
Dean valentini says is their greatest
college in the greatest university in
the greatest city in the world and I
think that's very appropriate so thank
you
alright so one more roll i have i'd like
to introduce our student speaker Brandon
Lewis he's Columbia College 2013 he
obviously have some fans here Brandon is
an urban studies major he is passionate
about communities especially the federal
and local policies that impact
communities and the social implications
Brandon is a long way from home he's
from Loganville Georgia he's quite
accomplished he's a kenneth cole fellow
remains active in the Columbia community
he interned with the Congressional Black
Caucus foundation he is a leader with
youth for debate both as president and
student teacher next year he will
participate and Teach for America he is
a recipient of the Marcy and josh Josh
crevette scholarship welcome Brendan
Louis
good evening Thank You mr. Brett for
your introduction for your leadership
and for your dedication to financial aid
here at Columbia there are moments in
all of our lives that inspire us moments
that affirm us moments that change us
and moments that strengthen us for me
this is one of those moments I've often
thought about finding a way to express
my gratitude to those who made this
education and this experience possible
for me and I asked myself what I could
do or what I could say to properly thank
you for changing my life and now I've
been given that opportunity so let me
try like many of the students in this
room I come from seriously humble
beginnings I was born to a single mother
in Birmingham Alabama in the early 1990s
my mother did not finish college and I
never had the opportunity to meet my
father and just as it is today the
prospects for people who looked like me
with backgrounds like mine were not the
best a story my mother tells me reminds
me of this fact and it's a story that to
this day she can't tell without crying
when I was really young I was no older
than four years old my mother and I were
in the grocery store and a white female
teacher approached us and what she said
the words that she said are words that
really changed our lives and she said
that she looked forward to having me and
her remedial math class in the future
now that teacher whatever her intentions
were jumped to the conclusion that i
would need remedial math based solely on
the color of my skin
painful as it was it was a defining
moment for my mother and I that hurtful
comment inspired us to defy the odds and
statistics and work hard to achieve what
many believed to be impossible I did
work hard and you all can believe that
my mother prayed harder and even as I
began to excel in my classes defying the
odds and challenging stereotypes there
was always a greater more painful truth
and that truth inspired what we like to
call in the south a come to Jesus moment
and that truth was that my family could
not afford to send me to college it was
a financial impossibility I knew I
wanted to attend Columbia it was my
first choice and truthfully was the only
place that I want it to be I was elated
when I received my letter of acceptance
but it wasn't until I received my
financial aid award that I knew that my
dream would come true the day that i
read that award letter inspired feelings
of gratitude feelings of relief and of
liberation I knew that I could
matriculate and my dream school and get
a world-class education and I also knew
that I would no longer have to worry
about crushing piles of debt or how I
would afford my next meal in my four
years at Columbia College I've had some
life-changing opportunities in the
summer of two thousand eleven I along
with 13 other students joined with the
kenneth cole community engagement
program where i spent my time working
with low-income New York City residents
to navigate the treacherous terrain that
is the New York City family court system
here on campus I lead one of the
university's largest service
organizations youth for debate and our
mission is to empower the youth of New
York City by teaching them the art of
public speaking and
debate to date we've taught over 1000
students in New York City and are
impacting more and more lives every day
and to those of you that are wkc our
listeners you might know me from my work
there at the radio station where each
week I bring the smooth sound of funk
soul and R&B to listeners of New York
City these and so many other
opportunities both in and out of the
classroom have enriched my life beyond
measure I leave here dedicated to the
fight against the serious inequalities
and barriers faced by millions of black
and brown youth like me across the
nation barriers that have been
constructed because of skin color
financial circumstance or zip code I'll
begin that journey this fall in Houston
Texas as a core member with Teach for
America so to the donors here tonight
please accept my earnest thank you thank
you for believing that my success should
not be determined by the labels attached
to me I believe I can say for all of the
students in the room who have benefited
from your generosity that the impact of
your gift will be felt far beyond the
corners of this room you've opened a
door for each of us to experience the
world in a way we never dreamed possible
until the students in the room like me
still struggling to figure out how best
to say thank you I say this live love
and give live every day appreciating
each moment as one in which you can
change someone's life love with open
arms ears and hearts and give back to
those around you and those who will come
after you we've each been given a
special gift and now it's us
it's up to us to love live and give for
a better tomorrow thank you